i took calvin over to [ __ ] i was with
kristen and i took calvin over to color
me mind you know what color me mine is
um it's one of those places where you
can uh
go in
and pick a like a ceramic thing
and they got all sorts of ceramic things
like anything from like ceramic spiders
to like coffee mugs to like um
uh
a vase to
a
hat you know you know not a hat you wear
but like a ceramic hat that you would
paint anything they have flowers they
have little village like mushroom
cottages and [ __ ]
and um
kristen was like i'm gonna take calvin
to color me mine and it's one of those
things where i'm like oh that's cool
that's like a mommy son thing but also i
secretly think she wants to go to color
me mine because she loves to do crafts
but it's a good thing for them to bond
with and also i want my son to be
[ __ ] i mean my son what boy he's
laser focused when he's drawing that
[ __ ] it looks like he's trying
to find an antidote for aids or some
[ __ ] i mean he's just serious will you
put him an etch-a-sketch in front of him
i mean my god dude
it's like he's [ __ ] um
tommy lee jones and been blown away
trying to make the last bomb i mean he's
[ __ ] with just classical music you
know
in the background
so anyway she was like you want to join
us and i was like you know what dude
yes i do
yes i do
i want to join you
and paint with my son
now is this something that four years
ago chris leah would have done or would
have thought he would have done
will crystallia have thought
oh in four years i'm gonna go to color
me mine with my family
no
but i did
and i went and i showed up and i said
calvin what do you want to paint and he
said i want to paint this and picked up
a [ __ ] ceramic spider and i said are
you sure and he goes yes
and he says oh and he looks over at a
vase and he says look at that
and i said is that you want to put what
you want to paint and he picked up the
spider and he said no i'll paint this
and i said oh okay cool and then he
looks at the skull and he says oh
look at that dada and i said very cool
skull huh and then he picks it up and
says i'll paint this
so now i'm like hey
stop getting [ __ ] distracted and pick
something
because i want you to i want you to
paint what you want to paint
being a kid is the [ __ ] you know you
just do [ __ ] until you want to do
something else
right isn't that it you're just [ __ ]
doing [ __ ] until
something else you get a hankering for
something else right like the other day
my son ate candy and then turkey
hey guy
that's [ __ ] disgusting
don't the sweets deteriorate your tongue
and then you want cold cuts
you want a [ __ ] dude we got these
like you you want these you want those
[ __ ] sour pumpkins those sour pumpkin
those sour patch pumpkins and then
turkey and mustard what's going on in
your mouth
dude
oh while we were at [ __ ] i forgot
about this dude while we were at um
color me mine
dude there were these two
i'm gonna assume females
you know you gotta assume these you
can't assume but you gotta if you're
gonna tell a story about them right
you can't just be saying everyone's they
in this story then people are gonna be
like but what were they and you're like
well i don't know and then get out of
that conversation
so uh these two fem
two women i i think probably because
they look there were women you know i
don't know i don't know what to do to
not get in trouble two
two people that were
you know
two people that had tits they had tits
and so and it's fine but and that's what
and not even in a sexual way they had
breasts how about that did sound sexual
they had breasts so two people had
breasts that colored me mine and they
were and they were adults they were like
you know 30
painting and i was like that's sweet
that they like to do that they meet each
other and they're at coloring mine and
the two
women probably they're there and they're
painting each other's [ __ ] they were
painting little like people look like
keepers they both picked keebler elves
houses and they were good dude they were
[ __ ] coloring it in and killing it
and they were both wearing masks and
that was one of the reasons why i
thought maybe maybe they're women but
maybe i shouldn't assume because let's
face it dude
the people who are really interested in
the pronoun stuff
most of the time we'll be wearing masks
indoors and i'm not judging like no
maybe not most of the time but i was
airing on the side of caution it doesn't
really matter to my podcast i got the
fan base it's all good and you're with
me okay but i'm gonna say that they were
probably women and i'm gonna roll with
that
and the reason why i say probably but
i'm not sure is because they had short
they both had short hair i don't want to
say that
you know that's also a stereotype men
have short hair women have longer but
that's and i get it women could have
short hair men who have tits can have
short hair women who don't have tit you
know what i mean the whole gamut these
people had short hair and tits is what
i'm trying to get at
okay and they were painting though
keebler else houses and whatever they
were they were killing it dude these
shits looked like i mean i saw kristen
look over and was like
oh yeah [ __ ] probably
you know what i mean
i could do oh you think oh really okay
well let me get my jar out and paint the
[ __ ] out of these diamonds on it
so
calvin
is a very curious boy dude it turns out
i raise very curious boys
when i splurt and they come out nine
months later they're very curious
so he
keeps pointing to the woman
and says
really loudly
what's he making
we're in a dilemma
and i say
oh
well that
is a little mushroom keebler else how
elf house
and he goes oh
and it happened
ten
[ __ ] times and kristen and i kept
side eyeing each other in hopefully they
weren't offended and in that sense they
make sense because there were two of
them my baby i'm just trying to keep
with the times and you know me i'm woke
as [ __ ]
[Music]
don't put some people call me a space
cowboy rubber damn damn damn help some
people call me maurice
that song sucks and everyone knows it
crazy
crazy
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
crazy
crazy
[Music]